[Music]
[Applause]
Sean Salisbury our good buddy former NFL
quarterback and morning host of the Sean
Salisbury show in Sports Talk 790 in
Houston good morning Sean uh first
impressions of your quarterback there uh
last night you all win on CJ Stroud
he looked like me on a couple of them
[Laughter]
you know what they should have done Sean
they should have blocked for him they
should try that that'll help that that
will help especially for a guy who's
probably not going to lead the league in
rushing from the quarterback position
Dan I and it's going to sound odd when I
say this but in a first preseason game
when you're getting four throws and you
know it's it's like with your great jump
shot four jumpers you're not getting
into Rhythm right and then it's when you
see a guy swim on top that's smooth but
underneath their feet are paddling
that's what happens even though it's a
pre-season game things move faster you
saw in high school you get away with
staring it down in college Getaway on
the interception the longer you hang in
the pocket in zone and your eyes go to
the receiver they're just driving on it
and so he played right into their hands
I love the fact that we have to go back
now and fix that because if he forces it
and it gets in there guess what he's
thinking oh I can make that throw and
then on in September it's a whole
different ball game because linebackers
can outrun running backs and these guys
will do that so I thought there was a
few things to like they do not have any
depth on the offensive line Dan they've
got to stay healthy and get Titus Howard
back but that will be Paramount for them
but he's really good in the pocket you
saw him Escape one time they're going to
live with him delivering the ball on
time great lesson of vision and getting
through your progressions and it's going
to be like that for a minute Dan it's a
brutal position to play and the
expectations are high but also you have
somebody that they're going I mean you
drafted him you want him to play right
away but is he ready to play right away
Davis Mills is a better quarterback than
CJ stronger right now is that fair to
say 100 percent Dan I went into this I
get asked this question about yeah and
davises and he should be further along
even though they're both in a new
offense you just see things a little the
picture becomes a little clearer right
because you understand the timing of it
that Davis Mills went through two years
ago in Camp when he was a rookie here
for me it's this I get asked well when
do you know the rookie should be
starting it in a game they're never
ready the question is how quickly do
they go and and can handle failure and
successes that go with sustaining good
play for 17 games for Davis Mills to win
this job Dan the reason you draft a guy
second is what Dan you're telling the
building we don't believe we have our
starting future Superstar quarterback so
you go draft CJ Stroud but you have a
guy that's pretty good and Davis Mills
that now needs to be on a better team
and he is for davis-mills to win this
job Dan if you saw last night which you
did Davis Mills plays like the whole
preseason and CJ Stroud looks like he
did last night the Gap is so wide you
have to start uh Davis Mills for the one
reason I can't worry about one guy's
feelings over 53 guys that I owe that to
to give me the best chance to win if
it's even or close you play the rookie
and I'm not worried about his friend if
it's a fragile personality if he throws
three picks because if he doesn't can't
overcome it I'm gonna find out real
quick if the guy Wilt stirring uh tough
times or steps up and I talked to Kirk
herbstreet this morning Dan and he said
the one thing he said everything thanks
says Stroud's going to be good the one
thing he's got a little bit of
is rabbit ears were criticism may affect
him we're going to go through that and
it's the wrong position to play I saw
some good things but uh Mills is going
to have to distance himself for them to
make the vital decision to play him
because Mills if he throws a pick in the
first game what are they going to say
Dan why aren't we starting the rookie
I'm not worried about personalities I'm
worried about what's best for the team
Stroud's got some strides to make and
sometimes you'll look at a quarterback
and then he plays in a system you know
like Alabama quarterbacks it'd be like
oh okay they're sort of the same and
then all of a sudden you look at Ohio
State quarterbacks and you go okay is CJ
Stroud like Justin fields and the answer
is no he's not able to be what Justin
Fields is he's a better passer but I
mean people are going to try to compare
them and like wait I thought you know
they're both Ohio State quarterback CJ
Stroud is more of a now he did run a
little bit when he faced Georgia but
Justin fields and it's all he did is
rookie season right Dad you don't what
you'd like you'd like the Pocketful
awareness and presence yes
and the monster ability of of fields and
put them together which we've got a
handful of guys that leak that are like
that listen we are enamored with the guy
that extends plays but Dan we can go
back in time and I don't care how long
it is Super Bowls and championships are
one from that hula hoop in the pocket
and then extend not the other way around
where you're at Runner first and oh by
the way throw from here so it's a good
place to start for Stroud but Dan
defenses are smart too they know that
you're going to try to make him Escape
East and West because that's not been a
strength yet when he had to call upon it
in that game against Georgia he was
phenomenal but it's not a it's it's not
a natural Comfort level for him but
throwing it is so I'm okay with where we
got to start as the base but he's also
got to learn to throw the ball out of
bounds and realize the hero syndrome
affects rookie quarterbacks they think
they got to make every play and you
don't the defense will be better but in
a quarterback that doesn't move and the
offensive line will be Paramount and
dictate their success us this year I'm
talking to Sean Salisbury host of the
Sean Salisbury show Sports Talk 790 in
Houston we had Steve Young on a couple
of weeks ago and he said this would have
been the perfect time for him with his
talents to be able to play because it's
about extending the play you got to make
the defense pay you got to go get those
extra yards he said that the era or you
know that there won't be Peyton Manning
or Dan Marino again but he meant that
that's just purely a pocket quarterback
obviously there won't be another Payton
or Dan Marino but he's talking about the
guy who just I mean how many pocket
passers like Jared Goff Kirk Cousins
Ryan Tannehill I mean he got a handful
of guys but it feels like the league is
uh you know trying to ease them out and
Dan you just mentioned those guys and
guess what none of those guys now I'm
not talking about I'm talking about the
Tannehill the cousins they haven't won a
Super Bowl right we now are at the point
where can you be you better be a two-way
guy you better be able to deliver it
from here and get out of the pocket as
well well and he's exact and we won't
have another Brady obviously because you
got to be I'm talking about Brady a guy
like that is so good from there he makes
up by throwing on time and accurately
for feet you don't need because the ball
is out like Marina was here's the deal
with Steve Young Dan and I since I
sincerely believe this Hall of Famer
already but you take his accuracy with
his four five speed and his toughness
and his football IQ and stick it in
today's game you know how we talk about
the overrated term Mount Rushmore
Manning and Elway and Brady and that to
Montana guess who's on the Mount
Rushmore if he's playing in this era and
a guess who isn't you see my point
because of the emphasis on oh there
ain't Gap listen you handle the Blitzer
with your feet and go we didn't used to
do that Steve Young as good as he was
then we don't put him in the top four we
say great left-hander accurate awesome
Hall of Famer it would be different and
he would have bypassed a whole bunch in
his group and we'd be saying man is
Steve the best of all time because his
ability to move before that was popular
and his ability to throw with accuracy
uncanny only he and Bruce Drew Brees are
the most accurate quarterbacks I ever
saw Steve Young's reputation would be
even better than it is as a football
player and he's already got a mustard
colored jacket
help me understand Aaron Rodgers with
what he did I don't know if this is
teachable like the way he throws he's
off balance I don't know if his footwork
is considered great but there's there's
certain athletes who come along where
you go I don't get it like Steph Curry
you just go I I don't get it uh but
Aaron Rodgers still has that weird style
um
can you is it teachable uh hell no dad
do you want to teach it right right well
if you do you better have a good supply
of body bags because you're going to be
buried a lot of people along the way
listen some guys come along I think
about the last two Green Bay
quarterbacks standing is a guy who
teaches quarterbacks guess what I'm not
showing them the mechanics of Rogers and
fars but guess what I'm telling them be
like that guy and be like that guy if
you can there you know I'm not teaching
Mahomes some of the around the back
stuff either but Dan it's amazing
because you look at Aaron Rodgers he'll
short arm it sometimes with that little
quick release the only thing I'm saying
from them is mechanics go watch how
quick the ball comes out when he makes a
decision from like a slingshot when you
pull back bam it's through the throwing
Zone and with farv hey see how he's got
guts to throw it in tight Windows go and
and be durable take that the rest of it
shut your eyes when we're teaching
mechanic jumping off two feet throwing
sidearm but Dan the common thing is they
both understood what coverage is to do
and with Rogers those and Dan think how
he changed he used to be a high ball guy
with Tedford dropped it and kind of let
him free flow they took the gloves and
the governor off him and said just go be
a football player that can't happen to
most because most Wilt when the
mechanics go to hell his don't I
wouldn't teach it but I'll tell you what
I'll take it every day and I know he's a
scorekeeper Dan and you do too he wants
to win the MVP he wants to play great
and he will as long as he's protected
I'm never teaching what Rogers does
other than the result and the release
and the back fact that he thinks that
he's the cat swallowed the canary that
there's nobody on the field that can
stop him which is a trait that's special
the guy's a phenomenal Talent the best
thrower other than Mourinho I've ever
seen when it comes to getting the ball
out all right who you taking in the AFC
East
um I'm taking I I think it's a brutal
division I'm still taking Buffalo
because I think all around there better
the Gap is closed I got three teams from
the AFC East making the playoffs the
Patriots are the one that gets left out
I think you have one team making the
playoffs from the AFC East why because
you think the division's too brutal or
you think it's overrated
uh it could be a tad of both but I think
you have to look at who else they play
they play the NFC East
so you got three playoff teams there and
then you got the AFC West
so you got Kansas City the Chargers
should be playoff teams the Raiders
playoff team maybe Denver gets it back
to you know competitive level when you
step out of your division you step right
back into a really really difficult
schedule so because of that I think you
might win that division with 11 wins and
I don't know if the other teams are
going to be able to make it in with the
Wild Card a hell of a point Dan and
think about the gauntlet like the ninth
best quarterback of the AFC is like we I
mean the gauntlet to get through is
brutal I'm still I I'm with you I'm not
sold yet on the Raiders of how good
they're going to be I'm not convinced
Russ Wilson even with the magician that
Sean Payton is I Gotta See Russ Wilson
prove to me that he's willing to make
quick decisions and then football but
what happened with him Sean I I Dan I
promise you even in a local radio show
we talk about Russ Wilson as much as we
talk about the local quarterbacks here
of
I I mean Dan I watched him and it was
like I was seeing a different guy 180
degrees different and one coach can't
change a star that quickly I mean
decisions thrown to close windows not
running I do not know I've tried to
bottle it up and say why so you got to
convince me that he's still got the
other guy in him and isn't more this guy
than the other guy and a lot of excuses
and a lot of rah-rah Russ Wilson's a
hell of a player but I I think his best
football may be behind him now Sean
Payton can Revitalize him you may be
seeing love like in Denver like you're
going to see with the Jets but both of
those divisions brutal but I'm going to
still say that the coaching and the
players in the AFC East give them a
better chance than most I'm still going
with three teams two for sure but maybe
three and that'll be the Dolphins if
that's the case should NFL players be
allowed to bet
slippery slope
um can you bet on yourself uh
I think what I don't think we're there
yet Dan now you when I say that I think
man do I have a problem with them
picking a college game I honestly don't
but we also have to know because they're
going to wear it on jerseys on fences in
baseball they're going to promote it say
no but you can't bet I'm still against
betting on your team just because of
what it does for the character and the
the morals of your own team and your
money becomes more important than 53
guys depending and Dan when you're
picking point spreads not just to win
you're picking spreads as well it's like
well wait a minute we're minus six I got
the ball thrown deep to me and this gets
us to -10 and I bet 250 Grand in the
game screw that I can't allow it to be
bet on my own but do I have a problem
with them uh picking a college game for
their alma mater USC versus UCLA on a
Saturday hell no but the slope is is it
like drugs do they become addictive and
we know when you chase money it becomes
a problem takes you to eat cat but for
the NFL the way they're going about it
it's awfully hypocrite critical to make
billions of dollars off a gambling site
and tell them they can't pick a
basketball game in the off season yeah
and then you know I look at individual
sports if you're a golfer why can't you
bet on yourself boxers get to bet on
themselves I have a I was reading the
article yesterday about Phil Mickelson
Dan with on Golf Digest I know you saw
it as well about you know with what
Walters and the possible betting on the
Ryder Cup when they got beat coming from
behind I why in the hell would I not be
able to bet on myself and if I'm the
Roger federers or Serena Williams or
doubt the doll you damn right on a clay
Court I'm betting on myself that's an
extra million dollars so as an
individual sport you're not affecting
the guy next to you in football my
betting is a quarterback if I'm on if
I'm doing that and we're minus six and I
throw it away when a guy's wide open I I
think we're that that's not just a
slippery slope that's something you
can't stop I think you got to stay away
from your own team in your own Sport and
people accused you of tanking uh when
you played but but you weren't tanking
right
no Dan that wasn't on purpose oh okay
because if it was
is that why you went to Canada
what's that oh yeah and oh Michael
Jordan went to baseball Sean Salisbury
went to Canada hey Dan the lead listen I
wasn't big enough for them to say Sean
we really need you to leave the league
right now because we are so good but we
got to protect the League's Integrity no
that interception had nothing to do with
me making a minus six bet for a hundred
dollars nah I just wasn't that good I
love it man hey real quick when's the
tour start and congratulations it
started already yeah yeah is there a
spot on the bus for me or is that full
or my invite getting lost in the mail on
the traveling bus uh I've been on the
bus with you before in Houston and
almost didn't make it back to my house I
was gonna say you almost died and you
wouldn't be having your your tour real
quick before we go I uh congratulations
obviously I know we're a long way away
from that you've made a huge indentation
on on this industry and on me but I
appreciate your friendship in that bus
ride I got a gift for you I'll give it
to you later it's probably just a
picture of me right there in the camp
I'm just gonna get you a picture of me
wait I thought I was getting your CFL
Jersey that you promised us years ago
and it's only CFL you don't want a
Vikings cheers as long are you going to
turn it around where it says Salisbury
facing the camera
blue or white
blue you want the one worn in the game
you want the blue one right yeah I want
the one where you won the CFL where I
looked like I was a player from yes yeah
and look if you want to loan it to me
you can
hey only if you'll wear it when you go
to bed at night
[Laughter]
I do have a bathrobe that says Daddy on
it so I I I thought you were gonna say
again John yeah
uh have a great weekend good to talk to
you I love you brother thank you I
appreciate it Sean Salisbury close to
the Sean Salisbury so
show